ce monsieur le premier ministre grise et
colère pour la filière betterave à sucre
éthanol française l'annoncé de la
fermeture de deux sucreries haqqani et
d'huile par le groupe allemand chute du
caire voici plus de deux mois mais cette
filière en danger sans compter les
usines de bourdon toury erstein
également menacé demain monsieur le
premier ministre c'est annonce affecte
plus de 1000 emplois directs et
indirects dans un contexte économique
tendu
elles menacent également la culture de
la betterave à sucre pour 2500 planteurs
et réduit de 10% la capacité
industrielle de la france
les deux sites se font actuellement
l'objet de plusieurs scénarios de
reprise mobilisant l'ensemble des
agriculteurs de ces bassins or le groupe
sud du caire ferme la porte à
d'éventuels rachats
il contourne l'esprit de la loire
florange en envisageant de laisser une
poignée de salariés sur ses sites
d'activités alors qu'un plan solide de
reprise a été bâti par les planteurs il
est inadmissible que vous ne répondez
pas aux sollicitations d'audience
que vous ont adressé dès le 29 mai les
élus et les responsables de la filière
vous renvoyez ce dossier au ministre de
l'agriculture
mais vous le savez il n'est pas
qu'agricole ce dossier c'est un enjeu
industriel économique et social qui vous
concerne directement
c'est à vous et à vous seuls et c'est
votre devoir
monsieur le premier ministre de le
traiter directement car il est impératif
que vous preniez la dcsp les
dispositions ont favorisé le dialogue
entre eux sud du caire et les
betteraviers français le statu quo est
inacceptable
la france ne serait acceptée la
manoeuvre d'une entreprise allemande sur
une partie de son industrie qui tend à
casser la filière française
que comptez vous faire merci pour vous
répondre
la parole est à m guillaume le ministre
de l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur monsieur le
le sénateur le gouvernement n'est pas
inactif et le premier ministre n'est pas
inactif nous travaillons depuis le début
avec bruno le maire avec le premier
ministre nous avons reçu déjà plusieurs
reprises tous les élus de la région
quand ceux des régions concernées par
l'entreprise sud du caire et la semaine
dernière tous les élus des régions
concernées par la coopérative cristal
union parce qu'aujourd'hui vous le savez
très bien
il ya un énorme problème de sucre
mondiale les cours sont au plus bas et
il ya une surproduction aussi à la fois
ci dessus tiers à la fois cristal union
se sont lancés dans des plans sociaux
qui sont inacceptables et gelé je les
dis au président de sullair il y un mois
nous l'avons redit à son numéro de la
semaine dernière la position de cette
entreprise est inacceptable pour les
autorités françaises mais ils répondent
aux sollicitations de la filière puisque
j'ai encore eu de président de la cgb
monsieur 100 derrière qui les a vus à
plusieurs reprises ils ont fait
effectivement un plan de rachat de
l'entreprise et d'un bâtiment à 30
millions d'euros
l'entreprise l'a refusée mais en même
temps l'entreprise vient d'eux alors
parallèlement l'entreprise
l'entreprise vient de mettre en place un
plan social qui a été accepté par les
salariés et
mais madame prima bien sûr c'est un faux
nez mais c'est une réalité et donc j'ai
eu hier soir le président j'ai eu hier
soir le président de la cgb
après que nous ayons échanger tous les
deux nous allons continuer à mettre la
pression sur super vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur c'est le
détournement de la loi florange
c'est une réalité c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement s'est engagé avec madame
pénicaud avec monsieur avec madame
pénicaud avec monsieur le maire et moi
même de faire payer tout ce que nous
pouvons faire payer est cette entreprise
et notamment sur tout l'aspect
environnemental
ils ont touché de l'argent de l'état ça
ne peut pas être sans avec
une impunité je vous remercie mes
secondes pour écouter monsieur le
ministre vous savez très bien que nous
sommes dans l'urgence la semaine
prochaine il sera trop tard si on
n'arrive pas si vous n'arrivez pas à
mettre en accord les industriels
allemands avec les producteurs français
c'est pas une question forcément de
moyens c'est une question de garder un
outil de production en france le plus
important qui soit le bassin le plus
important dans la production de sucre et
d'alcool et d'éthanol demain la france
vous avez très largement dépassé votre
d'ormuz oui bien sûr toutes les
questions sont importantes
[Applaudissements]